here's james barlow
living the dream dressed in a neon pink
lighter bow tie with a pocket square to
match surrounded by scantily clad woman
on what appears to be a cruise ship
he looks pretty happy with life
but if the government's account is right
the 44 year old army vet is one of the
most successful drug dealers to ever
grace the dark web
barlow who served 25 years in the army
reserve as well as active combat was
charged for allegedly running a
psychedelic drug trafficking operation
that spanned the globe the justice
department believes he was the
coordinator of the trip with science
crew
working with a number of co-conspirators
including his brother 35 year old
matthew barry over eight years the doj
claims the group primarily sold liquid
psychedelic mushrooms in nine milligram
files for around twenty dollars each on
various dark web markets that included
the sequel to the infamous silk road and
most recently on modern markets like
monopoly and television court documents
allege the mushrooms were grown by a
business partner of the elder barlow
brother while the younger sibling and
another co-conspirator would mix the
liquefied fungi in the u.s
then they would send them out to
tennessee and the uk for further
packaging and delivery according to the
doj
earlier this year investigators were
closing in recovering data from what
they claimed was barlow's google account
within his google drive they claimed to
have uncovered spreadsheets with sales
information for both trip with science
and another vendor he helped run called
perfect shrooms in one spreadsheet
investigators said they found data for
bitcoin income for each year between
2014 and 2020 indicating he earned
nearly 2
300 bitcoins currently worth 140 million
dollars all the while he was collecting
four thousand dollars a month working
for the us army as a sergeant first
class investigators noted barlow was
listed as owner of a handful of other
businesses with names including good to
glow and illuminated couture
both of which made clothing containing
led lights however the justice
department said barlow was not
generating enough if any income from
these businesses to support his
lifestyle
which included travel on private jets
world travel purchases of high-end
automobiles and ownership of multiple
properties
prosecutors are still tallying up what
they claim abalo's criminal winnings but
expect them to be between 12 and 15
million in assets across expensive
property two teslas two jet skis
mountains of cryptocurrency and loaded
via currency bank accounts the doj
didn't expand on how it came to estimate
barlow's fortune at just 15 million
the court documents claim he had
numerous expenses from packaging to
shipment not to mention co-conspirators
who could have wanted a sizable cut what
is clear is that in the justice
department's eyes he got rich regardless
you